man he's really done well for him yeah
he [__] wins the Super Bowl and then
literally
that's a nice picture did she date Pete
yeah he is like The Tonight Show for hot
girls who are newly single yeah
you're on the couch
and then yeah he's in your house yeah
it's like Leo is the opposite he's like
that's as far as it will go yeah Leo's
new faces it means nothing
but yeah it is just so interesting and
there's so much attention like Mark was
even saying earlier that there this
picture got 200 000 [__] likes or
something like that and the last one
that he puts up gets like 20 000. 332
000 likes in five hours dude that's
insane no it's got everything you want
in a picture yeah right yeah I mean
which is a naked hot chick yeah but I
can go without that yeah but it's funny
then that means
share this with your girl yeah this is
the diet coke of porn
I'm curious if they understand
the difference between the desire for
attention and the desire for a partner
then personally yeah if them and other
people that do this like famous couples
because I think what elephant happens is
like the famous couples are engaged in
this this relationship that gets so much
attention that they start to feel right
euphoric euphoric and they're like oh
that's because I love this person yeah
do you love the person or do you love
the attention that you're getting
because of the Euphoria is similar to
love right right so they conflate the
two that's a good point yeah I don't
think she understands anything but I I
also think she had a kid two years ago
and then just gave him away when he grew
like it grew to a certain size because
there is no evidence of him existing
anymore it's [__] Bonkers [__] that's
interesting
yeah
did I do that thing where I disagreed
it we both don't want a bad mouth her
too much but because you want her on the
show yeah yeah I have no interest on the
show yeah I don't want anything
with the kids
[Music]
I don't want someone talking about my
kids no no I'm just saying she's a bad
mother yeah yeah yeah
I'm also kidding you play Devil's
Advocate
[Laughter]
Advocate and I don't like her so I mean
devil uh maybe she's keeping him off
social media because she's like it's
probably because she's all over social
media
this is grandfather Yeah
[Laughter]
she understands that I just need fodder
to jerk off to on the road she's totally
cool keeps you Faithful yeah of course
it's like I have no interest in having
sex with somebody on the road because
I'll much rather smoke weed and then
beat off in my hotel room wow yeah
really yeah and I don't know what that
makes me but for sure that's just yeah
what about earlier before you had a
child
um even then man like I when I was
drinking I guess like even more like I'd
like to go out a little bit but that was
more about like I liked hanging with my
boys like I didn't like I didn't never
hunt for [__] since I I've been dating
my wife since I started comedy so I've
never been single as a comedian yeah
respect yeah yeah
no you're on my bus yeah my little [__]
I always thought it was kind of weird
when guys like I know we talked about
this like you are weird when when guys
would do comedy to get [__] I always
thought it was so corny what else we got
what are stories we got going on one
other thing about Crown Heights he
brought this up before which I thought
was crazy he had to move out of his
apartment am I allowed to share this
yeah because Bloods took over his stoop
yeah my friends too that's why we went
to stoop or yours my friends oh your
front yeah yeah and uh and like I told
them like they were nice enough guys
very because I'm not [__] so they don't
care yeah so they part you know and
allow my wife our kid to come in but
they're like smoking Blunts and there
was an execution like a block away so we
were like I think it's about time to
pack up and head out of here when was
this in a of 2020. oh early pandemic
yeah yeah they actually did they did
help us but they put a few boxes into
them what did you tell them was the
reason were you like were we leaving
yeah yeah
[Music]
I became friendly like not friends but
friendly and enough to like be like oh
what's up fellas how you doing they're
like you're getting out of here man what
the [__] hell you're leaving and I'm
like yeah you know you guys are here
how did they walking into a [__]
three month old through blunt smoke and
it's like yeah if I can't do it in my
own apartment does any of them live
there no no I mean so my area it got
really gentrified and uh I moved there
pre-gentrification so I'm part of the
problem yeah but but it got like he
moved there pretty I was there right
when a Connecticut muffin dropped yeah
so like that was the first signs that
there was something like the Christopher
Columbus of gentrification right now
yeah yeah gentrifying Hipster yeah and
uh and so I I had lived there and I like
the you know Crown Heights was awesome
because the food is so [__] great the
the people were really friendly and nice
jazz
real close so that was all well and good
but then once once the pandemic hit
everything reversed quick and then
squeezed and for whatever reason my area
was where everybody went so my
particular Street they have this liquor
store on the corner of Nostrand and
Prospect I don't live there anymore so
who cares but they have this uh liquor
store in the corner which was like just
[__] Ground Zero for Mayhem I mean
you know from the hours of like from
dark until morning yeah no jobs nobody's
doing anything we're all just kind of
yeah they're not like yeah hang out
abiding by any of the rules they're just
like yeah we're living life because now
we have free reign of the streets this
is the best and they just chose your
your stoop even though no one lived
because it was right next to the it was
right next to the um the liquor store
and they wanted a stoop though I mean
that's yeah that's wild it's a nice one
of them lived there I get it no that's
the weirdest part is like some of the
older guy like the old heads that would
just chill and like sit in lawn chairs
outside all day smoke drink all that
stuff they lived there like 30 years ago
and they don't anymore but they would be
there all the time what lawn chairs all
the time to hang out in front of your
stoop yeah all the time you think that's
normal yeah because they're selling
drugs and they don't want to do it in
front of their house of course yeah yeah
that's a normal thing yeah yeah no no no
no uh fine a place on the street makes
sense but they're selling drugs
yeah you need to sit
[Laughter]
you can be like yeah we're sitting in
front of an apartment what's wrong with
that whereas if you're not I guess maybe
it's more suspicious someone did not
give a [__] the neighbors are gonna go
hey like first of all if you're sitting
on a stoop where you don't live yeah the
neighbors are going to call and be like
hey there's some people are just
occupying a stoop where they don't live
it was understood man it was weird
because we were so you might be risking
your life the whites did that like few
of the new whites that moved in would
just routinely call the cops and they
knew exactly who the [__] they were yeah
because they would walk by and then two
minutes later somebody would roll up and
like be like fellas please disperse so
they knew who did that which is why I
never did that and and then you're a
Target exactly exactly now so they gave
a few of the people in my building a
hard time or at least weren't like nice
accommodating what does a hard time look
like like just not getting out of the
way and making them climb over them on
the steps dude there is nothing I've
seen like white girls in maybe the most
stressful situation situations of their
lives trying to like weave their legs
over gangster
[Music]
[Laughter]
breaking out into a cold sweat yeah oh
this is awesome yeah it's pretty cool
they were trying to intimidate you I
think dude not me personally like it was
cool
bro what is this oh blue you're right
this is a new thing so I'm saying would
you think about like what you're gonna
wear I started to and then I I don't
even realize they didn't care so you ask
them guys it's I can't plan around this
this is ridiculous yeah
is ridiculous choose a more strange
color
the blue and the red they really have
taken the best colors blue red yellow
it's rock and sock'em it's just crazy
you can't take the biggest colors
Jamil and I got stopped by these Crips
and they were basically they were just
like yo what that blue be like and I
remember rolling my eyes
like are we are you kidding me take this
up with Levi's what do you want us to do
blue blue
red is a little bit more uh they ended
up stealing Jamil's [__] bracelet but
that really happened but it was I
couldn't believe it I couldn't [__]
believe it
yeah
I didn't have a bracelet we literally
just got the bracelet in Chinatown
we were 15 minutes away from him getting
it and then yeah they took it oh my God
yeah yeah it was a time in my life I
said that exact
[Laughter]
yeah I do not like that at all no I
don't [__] like that at all dude get
your own [__] stoop and get your own
[__] stupid you know you live here
yeah no well that's that's too far
you're pushing it if one of you live
here Olympics you're [__] stupid
okay
when people from the building were like
yo do you live here I was like no they
better get the [__] out of me like all
right you're right
you're a comedian from Manhattan
I was a child I'm a child at that time
my [__] house
Andrew goes all right pay me go to that
guy over there
my Cannon is performing at the Gramercy
theater New York [__] City The
Gramercy so I need all tri-state area I
need quad state area I need everybody
from around you've obviously seen Mike
before it gets up every single Club in
the city you've seen them on the road
you see the stand-up specials make sure
you go check them out on YouTube you
don't believe me right now you just go
to YouTube yeah and you just watch this
specials right there that's it simple as
that you don't believe what I'm saying
you don't take my word for it go watch
him Crush online and then come out to
the grammar seat matter of fact it's
probably gonna be sold out by the time
you even look at them tickets so you go
go take all this time YouTube and then
you won't even have anything there's
already not that many left exactly so go
right now
mikecanon.com mycannoncomedy.com
mycannoncomedy.com go get them tickets
to the [__] show The Gramercy
the show is the 25th February 25th
February 25th okay go get them shits
right now all right and then after the
show make sure you [__] let them know
yo I came because I saw you on
playground so he's indebted to us for
tonight
I want the pound of Flesh